first of all I'm not I'm not sparing any
[ __ ] expense if I got a if I got to
be in these [ __ ] cities some of these
[ __ ] s cities like Buffalo I'm
staying in the nicest which by the way
the nicest place in Buffalo sucks donkey
balls where you check in and they just
act so insecure just cuz they want to
help you I love it said Leah and just so
you know there's a complimentary
breakfast you know we start at 5:30 a.m.
and it's over at 6:15 a.m. so if you're
a goddamn owl you can come down and you
can eat if you're an owl an owl and Mark
Wahlberg
that's who it that's who wakes up for
the complimentary breakfast hey what's
going on oh I get a [ __ ] a butcher
howls in here working out just trying to
be better gonna eat my complimentary
breakfast and then go work out with some
owls
make the complimentary breakfast 11:00
when you leave it when you leaving
tomorrow 7:30 a.m. ooh sorry the
complimentary breakfast ends at 5:15
a.m. those complimentary breakfast suck
dick dude [ __ ] your complimentary
breakfast that shit's free cuz it's
leftover
[Music]